are the only Kenyan to start a
photographic Safari and I said I was
shoot with a camera not with a gun I'd
rather the click of a camera and then a
bullet going in and my my pictures would
say with me forever of course when I
started that we were nothing the
big-game hunting Safari made all the
money and of course in all these things
you've got to look at most things always
go back to money today look we'll be
done Kenya ban hunting completely in
1977 alright because photography really
led by myself
was gaining and so what what damage did
they do to Kenyan nothing alright so you
hear these great conservation say oh my
goodness if you take it away these big
blocks of land who's going to police
them there's gonna you know there will
be poached it didn't happen then
Botswana has just canceled it has it
been a problem didn't happen because
they have a very high level a high yield
low impact of photographic Safari to
make this successful and sustainable the
community the local communities around
whether the admin where the wildlife
lives they have to be rewarded big-game
hunting everyone always quotes all we
make so much money you know we get this
with where's the money go I don't see
again local community goes to pressure
from professional hunter to the to the
government who gives the lease of the
land but what about the people who live
there what do they get nothing and so
what I did with my gorillas in Uganda
you know we have bitch waited the
gorillas
I built windy I got a purse waited
President Museveni to make it into a
national park today our gorillas we've
now habituated eight troops license fees
alone come to the local people
our company alone break 1 million
dollars a year in license fees do you
think we've lost any gorilla in 25 years
no do you think we lost Lots before
masses they were killed and their babies
were transported to zoos and so you have
to reward the community and by the way
that one idea of my highland gorilla
mountain gorillas they represent today
in the whole world half of the gorillas
left
in the world through my one idea
therefore we have 360 gorillas there and
there no more than 800 money gorillas
left in the world when I was born
making that simple there was say 20
million elephant alive today there are
500,000 elephant alive rhinos you're
500,000 alive when I was born we're now
down to just five thousand black rhino
left and 20,000 white rider elephants
are being killed at the rate of one
every four minutes rhinos are being
killed at the rate of one a day people
actually morally cannot go out killing
animals which are going to become
extinct and they were coming sick the
Rhino has ten years maximum of this rate
elephant 15 years and the lion - I mean
that we're down to 40,000 and so how can
you actually shoot a lion let alone I
mean the sense of one is appalling
because it had a collar around his neck
it was in a the Wang Yi National Park
it was lured out I'm told by meat but it
had a collar around his neck so I can a
professional hunter with a scope on his
rifle shoot this out I was like shooting
a dog these people should convert all
those lands to photography they should
have all the excitement of a high yield
low impact trip bring them out bring
them in camps cater on night drives take
them on walking but at the final moments
talk animals but at the last minute
shoot with a camera
you